is it possible to cheat in poker
especially online
we're offline also talked about the the
cheating controversy that's going on in
the Chess World
um is it possible to use what is it uh
remotely connected anal beads to so much
no uh is there is that a concern of uh
cheating online so here's the thing
it's kind of like a romanticized from
the old days like you know in the
western stuff like people trying to
achieve and have you ever killed a man
because he cheated no I have not but I
when I started out as a teenager I
played in a game with a bunch of
Italians and I knew they cheated and I
didn't care because they were so bad
that I could win anyway I was like I
knew they would cheat but I knew how
they were cheating so I was like okay
you guys suck but so here's the thing
anytime you're talking about large sums
of money there will be people looking to
take advantage whether that's live or
online right and so it's like the job
essentially of the you know the online
operators or the you know live event
staff to police it the best they can and
the players themselves being on the
lookout for it you know like a guy like
Doyle brunson's a great resource because
he's seen it all and he's seen all the
tricks you know and so live you know he
probably could spot a few things but
online there's there's various ways
people can try to cheat but there's also
really good security measures in place
to catch them you know and we've caught
in like about two years ago there was a
huge huge undertaking of like 500
accounts that were banned for doing
different things and you know there's
and again you can't go and they can't go
into detail in terms of how they're
doing it because otherwise you know then
you're sort of giving the cheats the
playbook in terms of how to take
advantage but it's always going to be a
concern for poker wherever you play
right
um but it's not something I'm worried
about
personally so it's the highest in person
and by the way online there is really
interesting algorithms that do some of
the work in an automated way to detect
to flag things that are weird but in
person it's just not something at the
highest level that you're super
concerned about so it's not uh it didn't
quite infiltrate the poker world to a
degree where it's a huge concern yeah
like so here's the thing I don't play in
private games and whatever right right
but in private games theoretically yeah
you know you could be in if you don't
trust the people you're playing with
like I've heard stories of people where
you know they have a new year piece in
that you can't see right and they have
uh you know like RFID on the cards or
something like that and they have a
phone reading it so they have somebody
in a truck telling them you're gonna win
this hand you're going to lose his hand
like that happened in a private game you
know and the guy what's often funny
about some of these people who cheat is
they're so greedy and blatantly obvious
they get caught where if they use this
tool in a more subtle way they could
probably continue to get away with it
but again that's not something I worry
about in a casino environment
um you know in these tournaments and
things like that but if I was playing in
private games like if I came down to
Texas and some guy I got cheated in a
game by a guy named Blackie Blackburn
and tex that's a red flag I was at the
chemo Hotel I was a teenager and they
saw me playing you know I was making
good money as a teenager I had like a 13
000 bankroll you know and I went and
played in this game with them in a
private hotel room and found out later
that the guy was a card mechanic you
know he was dealing and he could you
know deal your hands and he knew what
you had and stuff like that so yeah I
remember you know I lost the big number
in that game
and it was a good Learning lesson in
terms of
you know being wary of who you trust
yeah so if the dealer is in on it that's
one way you could cheat it's fascinating
uh that's part of the reason that they
cut
so like you'll see like uh there's a
burn card because what would happen you
know maybe in the old days is like if
you're sitting in the one seat I could
lift the car and you could see it the
next card coming right so what they do
is they have a card on top of it that
you burn that isn't the card and then
the next card is the one that comes face
up
I just learned about the edge
sorting uh thing that uh Phil Ivey maybe
others were involved with
I just reading it at first was super
interesting to me that you can exploit
the imperfections in the printing of
cards yeah that was almost cool to me
that that was that's almost not cheating
because it's like that needs to be a
movie
yes yes what happened with Phil Ivey in
that whole case is it's it's a
catastrophe really yeah it is such a
horrible precedent because here's what
he did Phil Ivey shows up at the casino
says I want to play this game they say
okay all right I want to play with those
decks they say okay they agree to
everything that he says he never touches
the cards he doesn't do anything outside
of the fact that you cards that you
supplied have imperfections on them and
he can see them yeah okay so that
increases his chances of winning he
could still lose theoretically right
probably not but he can lose in theory
he just gives him a little bit of an
edge and it's all stuff based on what
you provided yeah so the idea that you
offered a game I accepted I beat you and
now you want to free roll me that's
disgusting so for people who don't know
maybe you can elaborate and it's just
fascinating to me but you're exploiting
the imperfections and card patterns on
the back and then they look different if
you rotate it and the the fascinating
thing too when you Shuffle usually you
don't rotate the cards so that you can
see the in sort of detect which cards
are the strong cards by marking them by
through rotating them and the way you
know they're rotate is because of the
pattern imperfections yeah so some of
the cards like you said like you know
they have those like the that pattern on
it yeah and some of them this was faulty
cards on there we're not cut properly
yeah so like the eights and nines had
the card cut differently and those are
important cards in this game you know
the eights and nines or whatever so you
could essentially from looking at the
back of the card discern you know what
it's going to be you do nothing in terms
of like cheating yourself you're not
rigging the game all you're doing is
taking advantage of the fact that you're
playing you know you've offered me cards
that yeah are faulty can I just say that
of course it would be Phil Ivey who's
who's the goat at the at the normal game
it would be figure out this particular
thing I mean that's what if you're into
soccer this Diego Maradona has that
famous hand of God in the World Cup
where he scores a goal with his hand and
uh so of course the the referee didn't
see it they thought it was a header so I
mean part of the part of the magic of
the genius of the people at the top of
the game is they're able to exploit
all the flaws that are there it's that's
a beautiful place you feel like Phil had
you know in his Heyday he had he
exploited weaknesses and casinos you
know systems all over the country like
in one night I don't know if you know
the story and one night he would take a
plane a private plane and fly to 30
different casinos all over the country
because he would have these deals where
they're like all right we got this Big
Rich sucker who's going to come here and
play craps and he's going to lose all
our money so he'd have this deal with
one of the casinos where they'd be like
all right you get 20 back up to half a
million right so if you lose half a
million we'll give you back 100K okay so
he'd go to one Casino in Tunica he'd
play half a million he'd win win or lose
you know he would leave they think
they're going to get him to stay they
get him a big room whatever so let's say
he goes to Tunica he lose half a million
okay now he goes he flies to Atlantic
City he wins half a million okay he lost
half a million and one one half a
million but he got a hundred thousand
back so he's actually plus one hundred
thousand do that at 10 casinos a night
you're making a million dollars in free
equity and they would give him
promotional chips and all these kind of
things and free flights and stuff like
that so he took advantage of the image
yeah you know that they're trying to
exploit so this is why I don't have any
empathy for these casinos because
there's giving you free drinks they're
giving you why do you think they're
doing that kind of the kindness of their
heart they're trying to exploit you so
guess what you lost at your own game pay
the piper and I think it was crazy
because the judges in his case said
he did not cheat but well we it's
probably not right hold on yeah you just
said he didn't cheat you know that that
should be the end of the case